now for our members is who is the best
person to defeat kirstama in the labour
party at the next election i believe i'm
the only candidate who can do that and
my values are also those of our members
and i've got the experience and the
vision to translate those values into a
government that delivers for the british
people and ensures that this is the best
country to live work and raise a family
anywhere in the world the number of
people you sat around the cabinet table
with have been criticizing your economic
policy are you surprised to find so many
think it's a terrible policy
i've always said that i want to be
honest with the british people about the
challenges we face and be responsible in
dealing with them and people know my
track record i helped get this country
through an incredibly difficult period
over the last couple of years i made
sure that we supported those who needed
our help at every step with
interventions like the furlough that's
what people can expect from me going
forward and at a time of challenge i
think we need someone who's got the
experience to do that that's what i
offer but crucially for our members i'm
also the person who can beat kierstarma
in the next election and that should be
uppermost in their minds this morning
penny morden put out a tweet and then
deleted it which told mps that if the
final is rishi sunap versus list trust
then you'll murder the party that you
love what do you say to that yeah
this this contest has shown that the
conservative party actually has a
fantastic range of people in it all of
whom bring something exceptional and
different to the table i'm really
excited about the future of conservative
government in this country because of
that and i know that if i'm successful i
will try and build the team that draws
on all the talents and strengths in our
party because that's what britain
deserves so even though you said her
policies were socialist liz trust would
have a place at your cabinet table i
said this leadership contest has shown
that we've got fantastically able people
at the top of our party all of them
bring something exceptional to the table
but at this point the question for our
members is who is the best possible
person to beat kierstarma in the next
election and it's clear that i'm the
only candidate who can do that but can
you just address this
straight on be straight with us do you
regret the blue on blue attacks
kierstarma has just repeated that then
back to us people say it's a gift to
labour do you regret them and will they
stop what we've seen is actually a
debate about ideas which is very healthy
and it's good for us to debate ideas to
make sure that we get the policies right
for the country now people have heard
from me a positive vision about what we
can do i'll tackle our problems with
honesty and responsibility i'll make
sure that we support people and make
sure that we grow our economy and take
advantage of the freedoms that brexit
gives us but crucially i am the person
who is best placed to beat kierstarma in
the next election and that's the
question that conservative party members
now have that a few times just finally
have you been lending votes to other
candidates
absolutely not as you can see from the
results that have just been declared
this has been a really close contest and
i'm really humbled that i've made it to
the next stage i'm grateful to all my
colleagues for their support all i've
been doing all day today is talking to
them outlining my vision for the country
outlining how i'm the best person to
beat kierstarma in the next election and
i'm delighted that i'll now be able to
have that conversation with all our
members and hopefully convince them to